you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2016 I'm delighted to be
joined by Matt you and Tala from
critical role yeah
where's Sam our dad our third wheel is
Sam if anyone has seen the show knows he
is always late
okay perpetually so he showed up and we
sent him out so he can run alive he's
gonna run the lab before he can yeah
it's a bit if he was here on time it's a
band in the world would collapse it's a
terrible Rhino it would be terrible we
will hopefully get him on at some stage
today so at some point probably hope but
we're here to I guess do something which
I am both excited and very nervous for
because I'm going to be thrust into your
arms and you're going to make a
character sheet for me yes so how do we
start this it should I tell you a little
bit about yes kind of look I guess let's
see first off before we begin okay I
feel like we should roll some character
attributes so no sir of creating Adina's
and thunders and dragons character you
get to roll up your stats which include
your strength your dexterity your
constitution what what guides you
physically and mentally to go out and
mark your way in the world there's a
couple different ways to do this but
we're gonna do it your way
right right they're like your way my
system's up this one is a little more
leaving it up to chance I need you to
roll these dice on the table for me all
of them you know yes all four of them
sir and we're gonna drop the lowest
number of those okay all right getting
rid of the one that brings us to a 3 and
a 4 and a 4 that's an 11 so we're just
gonna mark an 11 down right there that's
the first he's good at math this is good
five more times and friend alright baby
wants a new pair of intelligence Oh Oh
12 all right look I define average
tennis habits yet whatever you think
better okay so you got you got four more
of these average I've always been a C
student that's kind of showing it's
showing that's good but dice don't lie
alrighty all right 14 practice makes
perfect respect on that there you go all
right
all right yep here we go anymore Oh a 17
all those perfect slick can I do which
one that is we will when we figure out
what class you want to be okay all right
depends if you want to handsome
character oh okay
to back that up now we have three ones
and mimic four oh well done that was six
rounding out that 17 one more my friend
well yeah okay all right ivory use up
all the ones down very nice that's bread
so we have an 11 12 14 17 6 and 13 for
those of you who haven't played a
tabletop RPG when you ever you create
your character and uh you know Dragon
Age this is where it all started you
know what all that shit's based on stuff
so now what kind of what kind of race
would you want to play in the game
there's the human who is generally
rounded skillful the a shorter life span
comparison to most but really strikes
their societal place in the world you
have your elves which are the more
either allude to erudite types or like
the more scrappy wooden elves in the
forest like the iclicker there's that
movie about the rings with the guy with
the hair and those I've heard about it
dreams it's great dreams okay fabulous
space gems
give me add water fallacious angry
daughter who likes to drink and rebel
rise
you've got you know halflings which
classically you think hobbit but
halflings are actually pretty badass as
well as you see later in that weird
trilogy that i was mentioning you got
gnomes which are tiny little tricksters
that have inherently magical entities
and they're quick they're they're clever
then you start getting into like the
more beefy beefy classes you got the
half-orc which is a fork half human
stronger inherent rage and blood boiling
anger savage you have the Dragonborn
which are like you know humanoid dragons
that have breath weapons and in the
vague enemy mind kind of vibe kind of
like bring it way back there for you
and you have half elves what you're
gonna happen pain humans and elves and
then you have tiefling yeah are people
with demonic blood in their history so
which would you like to be sad
I've always liked I think I roll the
tiefling when we did the the campaign
and and GameSpot I've always liked the
sort of like loner characters like the
ones that are kind of add on their own a
little bit like the wood elf was always
one I liked it's kind of like that
scrappy
I don't know like salt of the earth kind
of elf all righty
yeah so I don't know maybe I think I
might go for a wood elf this stuff what
else well we can do it now all right
so as your race we've got wood and now
that's what else that is your background
that is your racial history what what
kind of class do you think your
adventure would be do you want more of a
melee fighter who gets right up in the
thick of it more of a classic range
arrow user and that kind of like you
know brawler fighter realm there's also
a pallet in which are you know still
really good strong through our
practitioners or the combat arts but
they have some divine power they draw
from a deity that gives them extra
divine strength in the middle of combat
buff their friends and whatnot with a
thief class also be in that act as a
robe yeah rogue black rice which is more
about a sneaky and stealthy waiting for
the right moment to strike and do extra
damage you have Rangers which are more
of the Aragorn type and that weird
trilogy right well under the woods they
know the landscape well neigh and they
understand how to survive in the wilds
while still I ain't good in battle great
at a distance very greater than distance
you got monks which are ass martial
artists use their fists or month weapons
they have that Chi or key points they
can use to just do a bunch of additional
tax and just go crazy on people they're
pretty pretty cool you've got a you got
druids
jeez oh yeah there's a whole list of
these things I was like starting off in
Azeroth was hard
well the cool the great thing about all
this and the thing that you can really
take from all this is is this is about
the kind of game that when you're not
role-playing when you're actually in the
numbers game
yeah what kind of numbers game do you
want to play do you want to be on the
outskirts of the battle trying to like
find your moments to do a lot of damage
do you want to get in do a lot and get
out you want to be a tank do you want to
have more of a controller class and
being affecting the battlefield or do
you want to be the guy who just
rains fire down on everything there's a
lot of different ways to play the game
and like a lot of different strengths
and weaknesses to all of these but when
you're doing the numbers that's where
you're gonna be tactically and that's
where you're gonna want to be
comfortable so how do you want to play a
game yeah I mean I think kind of way
we're talking about soccer it's like I
think I like being on the outside a
little bit and start of picking my
moments all right then I also like the
sound of the Ranger yeah it's not work
is that yes or no that's that throwing
the land
yep the Ranger is that well it's almost
like being like a forest ranger yes in
charge of it yeah nobody touch my
[ __ ] chief I'm cheap rain down it's
like fire watch you play fire watch me
like that except with a bow and arrow
right do you want to be a sheep ranger
chief Ranger Sheep Ranger it is right on
your classes now I'm Irish and I'm not
well so maybe it should be capital
Ranger cattle right yeah Carol Ranger
I need milk and beef all right I'm
friendship cow cow Ranger Power Ranger
Ranger all right dude I'm D&D you can
just kind of like amend the class a
little bit just be like well you just
play a ranger but we call you a cow
Ranger perfect iron you can take
whatever specializations would help you
range cow I've got so many I don't know
what you perfect so now we have your
statistics that you rolled early okay so
if you want to be more of a range
distant guide you want to be like in the
thick of it melee weapons ranged ranged
you don't want to put our heist at into
your dexterity okay that's what you're
gonna want to do so that's what the
roles are about when you're when you're
when you're looking for the range it's
you're gonna be your dexterity stat
needs to be high correct okay all right
so probably like 17 into that one then
right all right yeah teen your dexterity
guy man after my own heart
perfect I like to I like to pull the low
one next I'm always a big fan of
deciding where where I wanted where I
want to suck I don't know if you've got
if you've got a Bible like actually you
go helpless I better grab something I
forgot offstage real fast okay figure
out your next set is I'm alright so I'll
be Matt Mercer for a second so the next
thing I like to do is is like one that
well on a numbers game it's really
really fascinating where your high
numbers gonna be because that's going to
be the number that's
to make you roll well just try and make
you a hero yeah your loan numbers also
gonna give you a lot to play with
because the loan number is gonna help
decide where your an idiot
perfect and it doesn't have to be where
you're an idiot you can actually decide
to be an idiot somewhere and you decide
that you part of your car can barely do
a pull-up and go for strength or you can
decide that you just always are getting
sick at all times you were just coughing
and hacking all the times and go alok on
you can go intelligence and just play
yourself and that's great you can go
play PD for a living man I know you can
go with your wisdom and and just be kind
of like I'm trying to the intelligence
and wisdom it's always like a finally
intelligence is the information you've
acquired through research okay and and
and wisdom is your intuition it's the
application that - it's the ability to
discern just the nature of things by
instinct and and and perceiving being
insightful the world around its
intelligences I know the name of that
plant and wisdom is donate that and then
charisma which is your ability to
influence others to make people trust
you to be perceived as well as worthy of
other people's time and that it's it can
be very useful but it can also be useful
to be really kind of a terrible bearable
person I feel like my carriage is gonna
be spending a lot of time around cows
and not people so I imagined that
they're probably not the most
charismatic person in the world chew
chew with your mouth open kind of guy
yeah yeah charisma probably would be a
good spot six charisma days you are the
wild man walking my way out of anything
all right all right so we've got rid of
the six and 17 the other ones you have
the eleven twelve thirteen and fourteen
place however you desire watch you but
watch this right I mean all right cat
Ranger what happens to a caring jerk
cows fall over because he spent the
night before tipping the cows over when
they were that's why he would raise cows
exactly I mean that's like fringe
benefits at home right you created good
for the milk don't forget to tip yeah
bubbles it up in yeah yeah I got cream
yeah so I'm probably lifting them back
up in the morning
strengthen this you strengthen there'll
be like 14 strengths baby alright 14
strengths coming up Constitution I don't
that's like getting sick and stuff yeah
or your general your physical hardiness
your islet e to resist damage or in some
cases digest the curdled milk that you
switched around last night exactly thing
the cows over also you're probably gonna
get a lot of cow [ __ ] on your hands a
lot because of all the cows you the only
way yeah yeah so 14 I guess that's 13 I
wish I hadn't seen that
yeah hot me for the rest of the day
there we are it's okay hi man right we
have a 1211 which one do you want to be
it's a huge difference necessarily more
intelligent or more wise or why you
don't need no bowl earning no we need we
need a sam riegel i feel like a sam
regal would really like you know here
they have graphics we can't write it's
like the show you suddenly walk in
Taylors
we're rolling a character a cow ranger a
cow ranger tom taylor taylor is your
character's name now okay
all right Taylor the cow a cow Ranger
okay sure you chose wood elf as your
racial background looking over here the
race he is he a cow who's a ranger or he
ranges cat ranges cow okay that makes
much no sense although I'm a wood elf my
cow is not really native to Woodlands
you you've you can you're pushed out of
the nest early right okay guns you'll
have to justify it occasion is so oh it
hasn't helped you get a +2 dexterity
bonus here next 30 is 19 which is
awesome beautiful whoa
you like that as well like as turning a
7 into a 9 is like super so much easier
than erasing it how is your glaze
already in real life yeah that's not
super high okay yeah this is what the
Dee Dee's all about healthy weight right
ants
oh yeah and I'm so charismatic in real
life but in this I'm just some bumbling
idiots true
about a week no that's you're gonna have
to let him play apply some method there
like really fresh down press press hard
so it's gone Ranger what what other
aspects of his of his cow Ranger
background should we develop on this for
a character background how is he raised
as a cow Ranger Sam what do you think my
calves from a long family of herders
right so okay so he can probably talk to
animals and stuff yeah yeah but like
only cows yeah yeah mostly mostly can be
bovine really I think we get fair vines
I don't know I'm not a cow Ranger you
would have to ask a cow Ranger right
well put you at second level so at least
you get a to first level spells and the
only spell that you'll know is speak to
farm animal okay far lentil is a
domesticated animals yes okay shooting
cats and dogs actually I like
domesticated animals is a little broader
to domesticate an animal okay yeah okay
that's quite useful that dad there's a
lot you could do with that yeah I care
just gonna be awesome
cheap domestic Gators as I can't if
they're not if they're hurt it wasn't
that I didn't do anything that's hurted
I mean you can certainly try and be
alright disadvantage you could talk
that's that's gonna be a rough one
alright I had a ranger at second level
you roll some hit points alright should
we use a d-10 right okay I'll go ahead
and roll that we go whoa good tells you
time
alright that's nineteen plus two so you
already 21 hit points okay that's really
good yeah that's that's very solid oh
you will probably survive a couple hits
from a goblin you've been drinking milk
I can keep licking my fingers is up
don't worry about it probably some
mushrooms on that you got to be careful
yeah there is that up your wisdom
modifier
christma in a -3 modifier right okay Wow
that is I'm just a [ __ ] you know one
like yeah yeah terrible at parties yeah
yeah that's like the guy who's just like
I don't want to talk to you anymore yeah
yeah I'll get another drink I'll be
right back you might as well work for
the phone company at this point it's
that yeah you're then it's gonna sit
down sadly one of the cows comes over
and goes like it's okay boy yeah my
charismatic with the cattle at the very
least even the cattle are like not
you're not their favorite range yeah so
being a cattle ranger what is your
favorite enemy what type of enemy would
you consider your most hated foe
Oh disease hmm okay I'll see you have
your favorite enemy first neighbor to me
is mad cow disease okay so in some wacky
game where you get shrunk down to a
microscopic size you can have benefits
versus okay cow disease let's say what's
a natural predator of cows that you have
to hide them from I was going to go with
the lactose intolerance generally but a
natural predator of cows I actually
didn't I could I can think of a few and
that's really oh yeah wool snakes
I guess alligator hates snakes sweets I
spent I spent some time in Colorado
there are a lot of like snakes bite sing
snakes wrapped around their legs and I
go and then they tip over the stakes are
actually just going couches Patrick got
rid of all the snakes in Ireland that's
right
and me have to go with the
lactose-intolerant is he gonna come up
much in the campaign it might it might
makes is probably wiser yeah thanks I
just have this idea of is this like boa
constrictor wrapped around a cow just
kind of standing there I'm able to
really do much about it at all I see in
my head he's wearing it like a boa and
the cow is doing a little dance on the
BOA when your character wanders into the
kingdom of like Mario all right sign him
to the cheese - oh we are oh yeah
absurdity alright as a natural Explorer
you also have a favorite terrain that
you can choose what's in the area of the
landscape that you are a master of that
you understand and can traverse without
any issue like the plains alien world
also like a tree of so I kind of are
what uprights right okay guys like that
one there's that wooden tree in the
middle of a plane sure because they all
get under when it rains so I bought it
I'm Irish my time in case you didn't
your favorite terrain is a long plane
with one this is actually come up in our
game is equation this is legitimately
bad thing where it's like what's there
one tree is there like an open plane
with one tree look like it has this some
sort of entity in this does it look like
it is we have a tree teleporter so the
trains are very important we keep hoping
to find that one tree like two trees
you're like yeah I'll keep looking down
in a bunch of Minecraft start seeing a
fighting style when you actually have to
defend your cows whenever they're like
being attacked by snakes or mad cow
disease do you see yourself going in
there with like two weapons in each hand
eat yourself doing more of an archery
longbow type technique you might want to
utilize a bullwhip of some source of wit
yeah
you can use anything you want okay
that's mean you'd be good at it but you
can certainly use it can I go with two
whips sure
I have never heard of this weapon
fighting wielding whips he's also got
the scars all over running how do you
know it's early years of yeah rough duel
whip-wielding okay Cal Ranger I'm so
excited for this no I'm like really I'm
on board for this this is great perfect
and for the hell of it let's play this
bumpy up to third level okay Wow
the boss is already leveled up okay well
that's your twenty six hit points total
now okay but also you get to choose a
Ranger archetype okay which means
Rangers can specialize different fields
there's a Beastmaster we're here for MN
which gets an animal companion that can
battle with them okay or there's the
hunter which gets benefits with their
attacks against specific enemies or
situations Beastmaster I think what
happened yeah okay master companion you
are the owl master
do I get to name my cow friend or is it
a different one you can like gods
what's your cows name but allotted a
bovine Vanya Vanya Vanya AI NNE does
that is that a person that you know in
life it's iris from milk nice all right
all right
Vanya Vanya you're killing it you're
killing it right now this is great
better fight away whenever I'm playing
World of Warcraft err D&D the easiest
thing to do is just like figure out a
word and like Irish okay I'll use that
one I know it sounds [ __ ] mystical
sounds mystical but it's never sounds
like how it's spelled Gaelic is the
weirdest language Florida's disconnect
it's like all Camila Sh cake and it's
spelled EA they own you together in the
game
alright so last couple of things we ran
into here we're gonna pick a couple of
Ranger spells for you we already have
talked to talk to a domesticated animal
animal something will come in handy I'll
give you a couple more Rangers to tell
Seuss there's a alarm okay I just
you can if your bed rest somewhere you
can set up a spell that'll make a loud
noise and wake you up if someone tries
to light you up on you knowing but
useful there's animal friendship okay
which I think kind of literally got out
in space
see there you go cure wounds so if any
of your cows get hurt you can bake oh
sorry Betsy and then make the woman go
Wibbly because I'm whipping all yeah
yeah they love you them cows they're
just excited it's like the sourest milk
ever I will say there's this detect
poisoning disease which okay having mad
cow disease I know that's that's really
salad all right I like that one all
right so detect how many of these do I
get I'll say I'll give you two more one
okay all right Oh general generous yeah
he's getting it all out of his system
now we play later today
you've beguiled him with your cow like
charm we also have fog cloud I mean yeah
you know when you drink a lot of milk
anyway it's bound to happen
right we have good Barry so we want to
footage your cows oh yeah okay seal them
up with little berries right you got
long Strider oh that's hot
I mean who's faster or you can you can
travel longer periods of time with that
issue
you got hundreds mark which is if
someone pisses you off you like I'm
gonna kill that guy I like that it's a
it's a grudge bonus basically yeah Sears
Point and then that's like give me that
one yeah something it's great I like the
alarm one right cuz I gotta be sleeping
with my cows and we're all just like
lying on our sides is like all over and
I try to put the alarm there and if
anyone comes up with tries to mess with
my posse and I believe you can choose
what kind of an alarm like is it as a
sound alarm or as a light alarm or yes
give me our big move how would you
distinguish that move from the other it
doesn't thought this you know the cow
master I guess he knows the true can
tell the difference all right don't do a
whip wielder you got some high dexterity
so far as armor goes I'm probably gonna
recommend you go with the lighter armor
ok biggest armor class pose not gonna be
leather it's gonna be a studded leather
or love you could actually be cowhide
you could actually travel that could
actually blend
oh yeah cuz their sounds are gonna be
like we know with padded armor man which
isn't leather ok yeah i padded armor it
is that brings you to a grand a sea of
15 great how much left we have how much
longer valid they were running out of
time alone oh no we're good
all right so there we have we have
Taylor the level three wood elf Cal
Ranger Cal Master walking alongside with
his favorite animal companion has a
spell upon ya
Vanya Vanya Vanya the cow charging into
battle with your duel whips ready to
take out some snakes or some mad cow
disease or the ability to alarm yourself
markthom is a hunter detect disease or
speak to your favorite domesticated
creatures purpose and you happen to be a
pretty ugly sumbitch you may have that's
why the scars are across to praise a
mobile whipping just taking a lot of
damage I think it's a pretty solid
character actually it's a really solid
basis ago coming across this guy in our
adventures oh we shall see I mean it
makes it so that is actually that's a
theme great thank you all so much thank
you for having us my character sheep my
favorite thing about this is I was
determined not to make it some [ __ ]
Irish guy and it's literally the most
Irish you gotta get one out of your
system thank you so much watching us
here on the GameSpot co-op stage we're
almost done we're gonna get all the
critical roll up in a second and talk to
them about asking your questions about
what they do here so stay there with
back in just a couple of minutes